let's jump to the story from Fox News
Zachary Levy Sparks Twitter controversy
over claim that Pfizer is a danger to
the world hardcore degree hardcore agree
I love this here's a tweet Lyndon wood
said do you agree or not that Pfizer is
a real danger to the world he said
hardcore agree and uh liberals went nuts
okay one less movie ticket to ticket to
spend money on stupid
seriously guy like he he's he does he
didn't like a massive multinational
pharmaceutical Corporation that's been a
fine some of the largest fines in
history 2.3 billion plus another 430
million from for uh five years prior
they didn't learn their lesson they got
fined like 200 million and I think it
was in 2001 or something like that they
got fined 430 million 2004
then they got fined again in 2009 and it
was 2.3 billion dollars and my question
is at a certain point why not just shut
them down you're committing crimes over
and over again you're done when a human
being commits a crime we say we take you
from your job your job is no longer
being done we put you in a box we close
it you can't go out oh these
corporations well it depends on the
severity of the crime sure but if we're
talking about a crime against you many
on the scale of 2.3 billion dollar fine
because they were selling off you know
off I I can't remember exactly what they
were what they were doing but they were
like
misleading the public as to what their
drugs were doing or something like that
well they'll let you know how quick it
is because at my restaurant if there was
case after case after case after case of
people getting sick after eating at my
restaurant I'd be shut down and there'd
be no question about it if if if you ran
a company if you were if you're in a
restaurant
and that restaurant was dealing drugs
out of the back door they would shut it
down every employee fired
I mean it's like sorry this company is
doing something committing crimes that's
right and and you know what it could be
it could be one manager who's been doing
it and they shut the thing down and they
say no no this is this is a criminal
Enterprise and then the people are just
like I don't know man I just make
burgers like too bad you lose your job
but when a pharmaceutical company does
it this is the reality of the world
they're too big to fail so the
government says just give us a cut of
the profit and keep doing what you're
doing so for the record Pfizer got fined
2.3 billion uh for misbranding bextra
with the drug bextra with the intent to
defraud or mislead the attempt
essentially according to extra four
justice.gov
um I'm not sure hold on was that is that
the 2.3 million 2.3 billion they were
selling it off label meaning that they
didn't get FDA approval for The Things
They were selling it for they had only
had a rule for the original thing and
they actually the FDA had declined to
give it approval for the things that
they were selling it for off the label
according to justice.gov
a big big mishandling well there's a
public trust there's also a situation
where this there's this drug Lupron
that's used for um for uh like prostate
cancer and things like this
um and it's being used off label as a
drug to give children to block puberty
to for gender dysphoria and it's also
used for precocious puberty in a few in
like some cases but it's only
recommended for three months at a time
and so it's not approved for uh you know
it's not FDA approved for use in
children for more than three months for
this extra purpose this gender dysphoria
purpose but no one says anything about
it and lupron's sales continue to
increase
they don't recommend the drug for that
purpose but they certainly just keep
taking the money this company ABV which
is a ton of drugs this is what this is
how it works with big corporations
typically the government just says look
give us our cut and you can keep doing
it a company does something that's
illegal makes 10 million dollars FTC
says it's a 5 5 million dollar fine sir
and they go oh oh geez oh I guess I got
to pay you have a nice day I put 5
million in their pocket I should specify
assist here that the FDA uh when it came
to bextra specifically declined to
approve so I think that they didn't say
this is bad I think they just didn't
give it an approval but they wouldn't
have to post it anyway Zachary Levy is
it Levi is it Levy is it Levy Danelle
I'll call him Levy he uh was getting
ragged on and attacked by the left so he
tweeted just one example of what I'm
referring to and it's at justice.gov the
largest what is the largest Health Care
fraud settlement in history it's not
anymore I think there's a was a
glaxosmith clients now the biggest yeah
three three billion something but uh and
that was later on but they're still
attacking this guy over it's like
you're not gonna go see Shazam next I'm
you know what I'm doing I'm gonna buy
two tickets to Shazam
and if nobody takes it just just pay for
it just I'm gonna I'm gonna give the mat
that the DC Universe Warner Brothers
money because they they got a guy
leading a movie who didn't say anything
anti-vaxx just said hey man be wary of
these massive multinational corporations
they're dangerous I respect that
and that's the kind of marketing I think
movie should be all about so you know
I'll buy two two tickets I'll buy two
tickets for you thanks okay yeah okay oh
maybe I will then oh we got tickets to
go oh no wait we don't have tickets we
have tickets to see Quantum Mania I'm no
I really do want to see it's a Shazam
theory of the Gods I'm really excited
the first Jam was Shazam was awesome I
don't know anything about Shazam it's uh
DC Superhero Billy Batson's a little kid
wizard gives him the power of uh Shazam
a bunch of gods Shazam is that like the
wisdom of Solomon the strength of
Hercules the the you know something I
don't know it's faster than lightning
he's always he's a little kid and then
he yells Shazam and get struck by
lightning and then turns into a big huge
dude and it's it's fun and funny it was
like the only DC movie that was actually
a bit irreverent I like the funny ones
that's why I liked Guardians of the
Galaxy yes it's funny you'll like you
haven't seen Shazam you'll like it no
okay it's fun can I take my kid probably
oh yeah absolutely she'll be like oh
nice we're going to see something but
you can see the first one the first
one's out okay it was like the best
performing DC movie I think because
they're all garbage this one actually
was good and uh the second one's coming
out and all these Liberals are yelling
like one month before the movie comes
out this guy's an anti-vaxxer and it's
like he didn't say any of that you guys
are nothing is like these Hollywood
people they need you all to comply with
their Viewpoint or else they're gonna
yell at you and it's like there's no
reason to comply with anyone's Viewpoint
think for yourself every single time I
mean obviously it's like making a song
this is why the Beatles were so great
John and Paul did not work in lockstep
they didn't know they didn't sing
harmonics of their words they sang two
totally different songs together to
create a mega song and we need more of
that what do you think better John or
Paul John really I mean my John Lennon
is one of my ultimate personal top three
Heroes well here's the here's the words
Washington and Einstein probably Paul
was poppy John Lennon was cool and so
together that was that was a you know
powerful that was the that was the force
John's willing to speak out against the
military industrial complex before it
was good I mean he had the cool glasses
think about like Paul's songs with like
what was that was that one he wrote
years ago
it's all like super it is very poppy
yeah he was the pop star of the band and
John Lennon is all like Vietnam is wrong
you know kids are getting dark angry got
beat up when he was a kid like just a
rough life love that guy do you know why
I want to add some Nuance to what um
Zachary was saying about Pfizer being
evil I think that what happens is
unfettered drug dealers are dangerous or
evil not not all not because marijuana
is a different Beast of caffeine is a
different piece they're both drugs THC
and yeah unfettered it's really bad I
mean like there's unfettered marijuana
sales in New York City right now you
can't walk down the street without
smelling it like every Bodega has
unregulated marijuana sales you don't
have any idea what is being purchased or
what is being sold you don't have to
show ID there's absolutely no regulation
and the city is trying to shut it down
now and be like no we're only gonna give
weed licenses to people who were
formally incarcerated or you know on on
drug charges but it's been like over a
year you can't you can't tell the
bodegas they have to stop selling loose
pre-rolled joints now they're not going
to
um and it's it's unregulated it's
unfettered and it's not a good thing
yeah Pfizer is a result of an unfettered
like a a system where they can have
immunity like moderna's right there in
the shadows if you want to take down
spend in the next 10 years taking on
Pfizer moderna is next and it's gonna be
the exact same problem which is it blows
my mind that there's regular people on
Twitter defending Pfizer I can't believe
that I mean it's it's the same it's the
same other people well yeah probably not
but it's the same cycle when it comes to
these pharmaceutical companies it's
creative medicine or vaccine or whatever
cause injuries destroy lives make 30
billion dollars find three billion
dollars rinse and repeat well that's the
thing I was saying about what we were
just reading with the off label the
intentional misleading these are these
are companies that uh if you pull up
there's the Wikipedia list of all of the
crimes committed by these corporations
so the the real issue for me is
these people aren't doctors I mean
they're technically doctors many you
know but you have a doctor that you talk
to when you're like yo I got a bum knee
they know your medical history they know
your family if you get a good one you've
had them for a long time the problem is
when you mentioned earlier they go and
Lobby the doctors and they say I I told
the story uh earlier I was skating when
I was like 16 and I hit my knee and I
heard it and I'm like I better get it
checked out doctor says nah it's a
sprain or a strain or something you're
fine here and then he handed me a whole
bunch of sample packets of an
anti-inflammatory steroid
methylprednisolone I think it was my
goodness and he was like just take a
couple of these and they were sample
packs and you just threw them at me and
then I was like whatever you say Doc and
I'm like my actor did that with birth
control pills like in little sample
packs yeah like a ton of them like here
just take all these you know this is my
family's doctor and when I was 16. and
you when you know what ended up
happening is I I was like okay so he's
like I took a couple of them and then I
didn't notice anything and the next day
I was like I don't know I just didn't
take them and then I ended up just
getting better because I was a kid
hit my knee and I couldn't bend it and
so it like swole up or something it
turned out to be nothing legitimately
serious or anything like that but I just
kind of I don't know man it's kind of
weird to me
you gotta you got to make sure you got a
good trusted doctor it's just that you
got to make sure that when they when
they hand you some like samples or
whatever you ask them what is it what
does it do why do I need it and if they
can't answer and they're like well it
was given to me then maybe you got a
Salesman and not a doctor so find
someone who can give you good advice and
talk to you about it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time